[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well among them these a
teen using her hobby to show others that
anything is possible no matter your
condition also a little brother who has
used his hard-earned money to make a big
impact on his sister's life what exactly
did he give her we'll tell you plus a
dad who bonded with his son on the floor
of the House of Representatives why this
Congressman brought his infant son along
for a big time vote
also a history-making coach and her
journey to the football field and a girl
with a special request for a unique pet
did her dream come true David begno is
there to find out we'll tell you as well
plus our heartwarming videos the ones
you just gotta see you're watching The
Uplift
foreign
[Music]
this is the uplift the show that lifts
you up for at least the next 30 minutes
you and by the way me as well we're
going to begin with that teen who used
her hobby to inspire others and also by
the way prove that no matter your
condition you can make any dream come
true here's Caitlin O'Kane with that
story many teens spend their time at
school looking forward to the end of the
day when they can get to their
extracurriculars and have fun for 14
year old Greta Bayer her hobby is more
than just an after-school activity it
has motivated her through tough times
the light at the end of a tunnel
Avery
[Music]
Greta has had three major spinal
surgeries at New York Presbyterian
Morgan Stanley Children's Hospital
S I knew that while it may not seem like
it in the moment if I wasn't already mad
pain
um I knew that it was that better and I
knew that I wanted to kind of my normal
life soon enough
um and I I kind of needed that the
motivates me so much myself and trying
to make nervous hungry as fast as
possible so while some kids can't wait
to get out of school and hit practice
Greta couldn't wait to recover so she
could dance
[Music]
express myself and not
I can do so many things that people do
not think I can do
um and dance with also just a way for me
to explore my movement and my abilities
and use the equipment that I have find
my wheelchair and create beautiful coils
she's part of born dancing a dance
company for people with disabilities it
really is a thrilling experience when
I've been up on stage and dance
um
I feel accelerated and it's so exciting
just knowing that all of those people in
the audience are there if you needed to
see my partner
dancing helps Greta Express herself but
it also inspires others
people like me May often think that they
said
and even the slightest bit of moving
she's a star on stage and also a star
patient for Dr Vitale proving no matter
your condition you can overcome
obstacles and follow your dreams
this is really what it's all about when
you see a kid on the other side doing
the types of things that Greta is doing
it's amazing and it gives you know the
professionals but also the lay people
the sort of uh courage and fortitude and
resilience to keep on going and uh and
getting to the other side because
there's so much out there that um that
Greta deserves and gets to do right now
so it's inspiring for everyone
for those who don't get to see Greta on
stage she hopes to inspire them with her
blog where she advocates for people with
disabilities it's the same look there is
a lot of ignorance for Learning and I
think that many people are educated
nearly enough on
explains like one of the right things
beside and what are the right things to
do and I'm making my responsibility to
teach people that
dance isn't just an activity for Greta
it's her motivation and Greta isn't just
a teen she's an inspiration I think one
of the most beautiful things about dance
and about Greta's voice in this is it
disrupts a notion of what people who
don't have the same abilities as
everyone else
can achieve can be like can do
um her dancing disrupts people's
preconceptions about what dance should
be or what it has to be I love the show
the things
I do really have an amazing life an
amazing opportunity and many people do
any of me and singing it I don't live
the good night it's fun I want to prove
that I do I'm doing things like dancing
mission accomplished that's a beautiful
piece that Caitlyn okay and we want to
move on now to introduce you to a
student athlete who selflessly used the
money that he earned playing basketball
to help someone close to him here's
Ricky Duncan
Anthony Leal and sister Lauren have been
best friends since they were children
growing up Anthony says his big sister
always looked out for him so this
Christmas you're a Sparky he paid it
forward with the ultimate Surprise by
paying off your student loan debt I had
tears in my eyes and then it just felt
like a weight lifted from my shoulder I
was thinking about like all the
possibilities like new doors opening her
brother a junior majoring in business
plays basketball for Indiana University
recent changes to NCAA rules allows him
and other college athletes to accept
money for their name image and likeness
an estimated 460
000 student athletes across the country
have benefited for people who look at
the payment of athletes in this way
College athletes as a bad thing what do
you say to those folks you got to look
at it from for multiple perspectives
we're just trying to make the most of
the opportunity we have how much was the
school loan debt that you paid off I'm
not sure how specific I want to get but
it was it was a good chunk of money I
mean doing good things for other people
it makes makes that person want to do
something good to like pay it forward so
who are you gonna go do something for
your brother had a smile on his face I
was I was thinking that as a joke and I
know she'll pay it forward so what goes
around comes around a model student
athlete and brother too
it's a beautiful piece here jurika all
right coming up did you see the big old
baby on the floor of Congress I hope you
did well they were there for an historic
vote we'll tell you why and I mean baby
literally from Congressman dad he'll
explain plus a seven-year-old asked for
what now say again find out what unique
pet she tried to acquire that is coming
up on the uplift
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift and upon
these pink pages I got those
heartwarming videos the ones you just
need to see and the first one comes from
Adrian Galleria in Los Angeles he says
his 73 year old Godfather Pedro had
always wanted to go to a music festival
so Adrian took him to his first the one
on your screen now there's Adrian oh wow
uh Adrian sorry Adrian's father Pedro
this is a New Year's Eve and as you can
see Pedro really fully embraced Music
Festival number one even got on
someone's shoulder there Dance the Night
Away uh I don't recommend getting on
someone's shoulder never safe at any age
but he's having a great time his friends
say they think he enjoyed it I think
that uh can be confirmed getting down
Pedro wow all right to our next story
gonna be hard to top that but it's a mom
who says her daughter has the best
reactions to gifts you decide
thank you
awesome million dollars
yeah I would say pretty good reactions
definitely top five nice video mama we
got another video from my mom uh it's a
mother of a little girl who's a big fan
of uh CBS mornings uh take a look here
now at 19 month old Caroline Jones
dancing to the if you hear it there hope
you know it CBS morning's theme song her
mom Jessica Jones says she loves dancing
to the song every morning and even tries
to sing along but I got a little tip I
try to sing along too until I realize
just a theme song there are no words
coming up a congressman who brought a
very special guest to the house floor
we'll tell you why this baby that one
right there on his chest was there in
his arms as political history was being
made
[Music]
and a history-making football coach
talks about the moment she knew she had
made it
Mimi Bolden Morris spent her life around
football and now she's making history in
football here's Dana Jacobson with more
so one of my first couple weeks of the
season I had one girl who just had
gotten into Michigan and she was like
waiting on the steps to talk to me just
to have a conversation about what I'm
doing
um how she can get involved in football
and just really to get to know me I was
like I was so shocked I was like okay
like I'm now I see you see it I see it
yeah oh that's cool 23 year old Mimi
Bolden Morris may already be a role
model for other women as a grad
assistant on the University of Michigan
football team working with the
Wolverines quarterbacks yet she's the
first to admit it's a position she
didn't always see herself in I can't
think of a woman who would have even
been in a coaching position when you
were a kid that you would have seen no
none my dad was my brother's coach my
whole life I was his water girl but I
didn't really think that would be my
thing I thought I was going to be a
doctor but as a kid football was
definitely Italy in her blood her
younger brother Mike currently a star
defense event at Michigan remembers his
big sis as his flag football quarterback
what's her arm like
I was just a rocket did she always as a
kid she had a rocket over the arm I want
her to be my quarterback my mom won't
let her
mom the mom mom wanted to be a
cheerleader all the girly stuff but she
wanted to play football Mike said he
wanted you as his quarterback but Mom
didn't want you to keep playing no
she didn't my dad would let me play
quarterback at my brother's practices
and she wasn't having it she wanted me
to be her mini me but bold and Morris
stuck with sports earning a basketball
scholarship to play at Boston College
for three seasons followed by Georgetown
where she'd lead the Hoyas in scoring
her final year gonna stick with the zone
you have to mark her at all times
there's Milan Bolden Morris while still
playing basketball at Georgetown Bolden
Morris set her sights on coaching
football that's when her mom stepped in
my mom
reached out to kotar ball your mom who
you just moments ago described it was
the dance team the cheerleading yeah
your mom reached out because your
brother was playing here and I didn't
know
until I got a call
from coach
and I was like
what after like a bunch of conversations
kind of testing my knowledge seeing what
I was doing at Georgetown and he asked
me to be the ga and I was like oh my
gosh I was so speechless
um
and I mean here I am Michigan had coach
Jim Harbaugh remembers the calls he says
Bolden Morris stood out for her work
ethic and drive to get in the game she
didn't even tell me this I found out
from the georgetown's coaches that she
was volunteering on the Georgetown
football staff right she just wanted to
be ready she's not scared she's been in
pressure situations she's got a great
Focus but also a looseness of somebody
that's actually been there and done it
right and has her own ideas I love it
when she you know coaches why are you
doing it that way don't you think this
way might be a little bit better for
bold and Morris it's how she's always
been and she knows with her success
others will have a chance to follow I'm
excited because like there's a whole new
mind to mine gold from that right I
didn't know existed and the great thing
is Mimi turned us all on to that
possibility what does that mean to know
that just by being here you're already a
role model for so many I'm just so
blessed that God put me in this position
to be able to inspire and my only hope
is that by me doing what I'm doing it
inspires others to do what it is that
they want and know that they can
sure it is already doing that we are
going to turn now to congress not always
an inspiring place and you may not think
it can be uplifting not at all but an
uplifting story did actually make its
way from the house floor in the middle
of a contentious debate and rounds and
rounds of voting
one Congressman proved there is room for
heartwarming moments even in politics
these days here's Caitlin Huey burns
with more
well Republicans were desperately
searching for votes to elect a speaker
Democrat Jimmy Gomez of California was
on a different kind of hunt you want
that for baby supplies we weren't
expecting to be here this long we had to
buy more wipes we had to buy stuff to
keep them entertained
I can't find the socks It's been a
challenging but it's been fun Gomez has
planned to return home with his family
once he was sworn in was put on hold as
the speaker fight dragged on and his
wife needed to get back to work she has
an important job and we've always said
that
um the you know she was what the mom
wouldn't be the default parent Gomez so
Gomez and four-month-old Hodge got some
father-son bonding time on the house
floor fitting bottle feeds and naps in
between votes and mastering quick diaper
changes in the Democratic cloak room
where he bonded with fellow dads in
Congress I hope that it sends a a
positive message where dads need to do
their part you know the Mom shouldn't be
the one that automatically has to give
up their career in order for the Family
schedule to work out a message he hopes
can get majority support you got this
looking like a pro already coming up
find out the unique request that a
seven-year-old made the local
authorities and meet the stranger not a
stranger to us who helped her pursue her
dream that's all coming up after the
break
[Music]
when a seven-year-old made a unique
request for a pet strangers stepped in
to help her pursue her dream here's
David begno with her story
here's my room
enter Madeline's world and you come
under the mystical spell of a mythical
creature what is it that makes unicorns
so special that their magical horn
it grants you magic wishes if you ask
yeah double rainbows in the sky magic
purple butterflies at seven years old
she is obsessed with unicorns they live
in the magical forest of Scotland
that fictional Beast so beloved and
popular is the real national animal of
Scotland in Celtic mythology it is a
symbol of Purity innocence and Power
and have you been to Scotland no so
what's the plan to get your unicorn well
I'm going to take a airplane okay and
then I'm going to find the unicorn in
the magical forest and bring it back on
the airplane
Madeleine has been smitten with the
Unicorn since she was three years old
and can tell you anything you want to
know and what else is involved in taking
care of it
making sure it sees rainbows sunlight
and Moonbeams so I'm going to make the
barn have a glass roof back in November
Madeline told her mom Leilani that she
wanted a real unicorn so Mom suggested
that Madeline learn the rules about
owning a large animal by writing to the
Los Angeles County Department of animal
care and control I would like permission
if I could have a unicorn in my backyard
if I could find one now Mom there are
things over the course of our life that
we explore and come to understand what's
your intention sort of behind going
through the process with Madeline well
Madeleine's a very curious little girl
anything that she proposes we want to
encourage and support so when she came
up to me with this idea I thought okay
we can do this but let's do it through
the proper measures of seeing what's
required to maintain such a large animal
Marcia mayetta the director of Animal
Care and Control for L.A County she got
Madeline's letter and she wrote her back
the first requirement
does that she comply with all County
regulations by keeping animals that she
had to feed the Unicorn watermelon at
least once a week because that's their
favorite treat she had to polish the
unicorn's horn at least once a month
with a soft cloth and any Sparkles or
glitter used on the Unicorn must be
non-toxic and biodegradable of course
well after agreeing to follow those
rules Madeleine visited the Animal Care
Center on her seventh birthday to get
her unicorn license the first ever issue
by LA County it is bigger than me I
think the takeaway for parents is to
support your children's dreams you know
don't stifle them I think it's really
important that adults do that
when L.A County shared Madeleine's story
on social media it went viral touching
Hearts around the world I would just
like to thank you for reducing me to a
blubbering weeping mess when I read
about your beautiful piece of kindness
to Madeline I'm a six foot two hundred
and forty pound piece of British meat
who has seen his fair share of savagery
and nastiness in the world animals and
humans alike should be grateful as you
make the world a better place we're just
kind of riding on that wave of Joy
while our fascination with the Unicorn
goes back to ancient times they are as
popular as ever today
and what's the takeaway for everybody
who felt something from this story that
there's really still a lot of that
innocence and just pure joy still out
there and it's a lot of fun to follow
and we'll get a book to read to you
after all a child's imagination is
boundless I
I've learned
if you want something then you have to
ask for it and to ask for it you have to
do something to ask for it I love it
for some more David begno stories I hope
we get them because that closes out our
show and it does a beautiful job of it I
hope this news brighten your day I hope
it lifted you up if it did you know what
I always say reruns they're free I'm
gonna go find some more good news
foreign